if the UN hadn't already made severe
cuts to its budget it wouldn't have had
enough money to stage the high-level
week of the UN General Assembly when
world leaders visited New York last
month
Secretary General Antonio Guterres said
the organization is confronting its
worst financial situation in a decade
the organization is facing a severe
financial crisis to be more specific as
severe liquidity crisis the equation is
simple without cash the budget cannot be
properly implemented our work and our
reforms are at risk the
secretary-general was very clear about
the dire problems the UN is facing but
at no point did he list the countries
that are causing it by not paying what
they owe and surely you've got a big
problem here and you need to name the
people responsible for it there's 193
member states 129 have paid up in full
the balance that's not of those who
haven't paid the US which has the
largest GDP in the world owes by far the
most a sum of over 1 billion and 55
million dollars that's more than all the
other 63 countries on the list of those
who haven't paid put together the u.s.
also owes well over 2 billion dollars to
the separate UN peacekeeping budget
James BAE's al Jazeera of the United
Nations